the Japanese and Koreans hate each other
well the Japanese colonized Korea for 50
years and didn't even let them speak
their own like if I had anything
Japanese go on TV my dad would go for
Godzilla they were also the Rimmer I
mean one of the things that it's very
hard to talk about but in World War 2 a
lot of Koreans were women were forced
into prostitution
to be to service the Japanese here Bobby
where do you think I grew up so come on
man dude you have intensity do I have an
accent mmm no just can be real I am man
I'm curious yeah I grew up in San Diego
I figure you grew up in LA not saying
why I had so many prostitutes before I
really got a good real girl
why because I grew up in San Diego and I
couldn't get laid because I was pretty
much unfuckable ya know I was short and
San Diego's gotta be joking look at
ching ching laughing ching ching but I
we used to go in high school like we
used to go to Adelitas which is you know
the biggest brothel in Tijuana yeah and
we used to do these things called
trifectas where we do 3 & a 9 ah
you know of course yeah I couldn't go
now that's not don't think that you're
talking to the dirtbag over here I know
I fact this keep no I mean these are
things that I did in the past that like
I'm not proud of but well you have to
survive and so I white chicks didn't
like me then and then so I had to get
laid and then once I started doing
standing by 23 it started flowing on a
regular basis so then I was cool with it
but there's nothing worse for a young
man that when he can't get access to
what I know it's so frustrating this guy
over here to my left doesn't have a clue
as to what that's about you know you've
always killed it well look at him look
at me right now you've always killed it
I would say kill his you know varsity
blues you know that that movie yeah
that's his [ __ ] life this [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
Colorado softie over here what was the
Colorado soft you always got everything
he [ __ ] wanted look at him you know
how I know I lost my virginity I was at
a party in high school I was on the
wrestling team
and I was the lightest weight and there
was a girl they say I'll [ __ ] everyone
you know so the heavyweights
all the way down to the lightweights
back to [ __ ] or announce last yeah but I
waited patiently in the room like I
remember had my hands in my pocket and I
was just whistling you know and then I
got in there I like I stuck it it was
like a [ __ ] Batcave I bet yeah and I
stuck it in there I didn't feel anything
but I came anyway because just the idea
of oh like that and then I felt like but
whether hates you know that man I
remember when when AIDS was we didn't
know what what you know you'd have sex
and I would get like us cold in my
glands would swell and I buy the worst
I've ever seen a hypercar dude I was at
F Street bookstore when I was a in 19mm
F Street bookstore are these uh they're
porn store not porn yeah like adult
bookstores in San Diego yeah and they
have those rooms in the back right where
the floors really sticky yeah so I
remember one night I was waiting tables
and I went to F Street and I you could
lock in and you know you can change ten
of channels by these little buttons and
it did a button and it was [ __ ]
calming it oh no like that all right
I looked at my finger and there was a
little cut there ah do I die of AIDS oh
my god yeah I thought I had full-blown
AIDS
yeah what I did it you know why I've
never met a Korean with each you guys
have you ever met a Korean with AIDS
well there you go
I'm not saying that I can't get it yeah
I think my body's pretty like yes yeah
yeah yeah when you see my back I pull
myself up like a champ like a champ
through 30 times while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gif it's a gift it's a gift